curiosity intrigue and excitement are at
an all-time high for dc fans right now
this is especially true after fan dome's
recent release of the official trailer
for the batman here are some of the
small details from the trailer that you
might have missed
dc fandom treated fans to plenty of
teasers and news thus far but the most
exciting reveal was this official
trailer drop it offers a much better
look at what to expect from matt reeve's
take on the dc universe as well as
showing more of robert pattinson's
brutal approach to crime fighting as the
caped crusader the footage we've seen so
far gives us a much scrappier ferocious
batman than many people were expecting
it also leans heavily into the noir
detective aspect of the character in
fact dc actually stands for detective
comics so for many long time fans of the
character this feels like a restoration
the dark knight isn't the only figure to
stand in the spotlight of course as the
trailer shows off zoe kravitz's catwoman
and colin farrell's oswald cobblepot aka
the penguin however the focus is kept on
whatever it is paul dano's riddler has
in store for gotham city he's clearly
targeting the corrupt institutions of
gotham and that somehow ties back to
batman himself but the trailer is
careful to keep the villain shrouded in
mystery he's everywhere and nowhere and
that's perhaps the most important
revelation of the trailer
the trailer kicks things off with a swat
team and commissioner gordon played by
jeffrey wright arresting the riddler in
a coffee shop on a dreary gotham night
he leaves behind his trademark calling
card in the form of a question mark milk
pattern in his coffee but we never
actually see dana's face when he's
arrested the trailer purposefully
obscures the villain and later footage
only shows him wearing a mask when a
news report pops up on a tv screen
featuring one of the riddlers live
streams even when the riddler is about
to be interrogated by batman the screen
lifts up showing the villain in a prison
uniform just as the trailer is about to
show his full look it cuts away maybe
there's something unique about dano's
take on the character that warner
brothers is saving for a later trailer
or poster whether that's some kind of
facial disfigurement a scar or even a
tattoo it's also entirely possible that
this is a bait and switch after all
what's scarier than a twisted psychopath
who looks completely normal it'd be
surprising if the film only ever shows
us the riddler when he's wearing the
mask either way whatever warner brothers
is hiding it's definitely having the
intended effect of turning up the
intrigue
after the trailer's suspense filled
opening we see a moody shot of a group
of gang members sitting together on a
train before batman beats them all to a
bloody pulp in a ruined building they
look eerily reminiscent of the goons in
the joker's gang who all wear face paint
to emulate the clown prince of crime
although it's worth noting that they're
not wearing true clown makeup the
imagery is certainly evocative of
joker's gang so does this mean a version
of the joker exists in this version of
the dc universe perhaps he's already an
established villain or maybe he's just
waiting in the wings either way the
goons definitely look like they're tied
to gotham's super villain population we
know that the batman will not take place
in the same universe as todd phillips
joker so the chances of seeing joaquin
phoenix pop up in a gritty cameo are
basically zero
though that doesn't mean that some
version of the joker doesn't exist in
reeves gotham the batman is already
starting to feel a little stuffed so it
would take a lot of narrative muscle to
shoehorn in another a-list villain still
that doesn't mean joker isn't out there
somewhere waiting in the wings for a
sequel
another eerie shot in the trailer shows
the new version of the bat signal
lighting up the gotham skyline with
commissioner gordon calling for batman's
assistance the fact that someone has
built the light and gordon is operating
it suggests that batman has been working
alongside gordon and the gotham city
police department given how hands-on
bruce and alfred played by andy circus
seemed to be with their equipment it's
most likely they built it together it's
a notable shot because it seems to set
up a gotham law enforcement paradigm in
which batman is already working hand in
hand with the gotham police
in fact the first trailer already
confirmed that batman is well known to
the police as he's seen stepping into
the crime scene with the duct-taped
victim among all the detectives and
officers then again we also see a number
of officers chasing him in this new
trailer just before he leaps from a
skyscraper so whatever formal
arrangement batman has worked out with
the commish at this point we're guessing
he doesn't always keep his vigilante
work on the up and up
you can't have a batman movie without a
great suit and awesome accessories for
him to save the day in even compared to
the many iterations of the caped
crusader we've seen on screen over the
years this one looks to be extra lethal
thanks to the fancy gadgets he's packing
the most noticeable factor with
pattinson's threads though is just how
diy it all feels but in the best way
possible pattinson's bruce has clearly
been hard at work to transform himself
into an unstoppable vigilante from the
trailer's brief glimpses of batman in
action we can see that this suit has
some serious stopping power he's
bulletproof and rocking an electrified
gauntlet to boot he also appears to be
wearing a squirrel style wingsuit at one
point rather than the traditional bat
cape it all adds up to a deadly set of
threads one that ensures this take on
the bat is one you really don't want to
mess with
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]